MATTHEW O'CONNOR:
Good afternoon.
My name's Matt O'Connor.
I'm a product manager from
Google's Cloud Platform.
And this is Aaron Philipp.
He joins from one
of our partners,
PricewaterhouseCoopers.
And we're talking a little
about some cloud security today.
And we really appreciate
you guys sticking it out,
because we realize we're the
last stop before cocktails.
So hopefully we'll make this
interesting for you all.
Niels this morning spoke
a lot and gave you guys
a good overview of what
we've done to secure Google
and to secure the cloud.
What I was going to talk
about a little bit here today
is I was going to talk about
our perspective on security
from a Google point of
view, to hopefully seed
some thoughts with you all as
you look to taking advantage
of the cloud and be able to take
advantage of some of the way we
think about things.
First of all, we live in
kind of a rough world.
And so one of the things
that we are constantly doing
is we're constantly doing a risk
analysis of things that we do.
And we're assessing
our environment
to help us make
informed decisions.
What I'm showing
you here is, this
is an example of what kind
of the network weather
looked like back in May.
This is called the
Digital Attack Map.
You can go find this
online and look at it.
And you can see kind of
the weather for today.
But this is showing
DDoS attacks and stuff,
and we get a lot of this kind
of traffic on our network.
And so we've built
capabilities to protect
a lot of our services.
Some of our cloud products
take advantage of that.
For example, if you're using
our App Engine product,
you're shielded from
these kinds of attacks.
But I'm just trying
to give you a sense
of the global environment
that we live in.
We also think
about, there's kind
of the traditional
security model
where we're hard on the
outside, soft on the inside.
And so one of the
assumptions that we're
making from a
Google point of view
is that the network
is compromised
and that the threat
is close to us.
And so we're constantly
working on defense in depth
and doing smart kinds of
things to minimize our risk,
but also simplify
the way we do things
to help us mitigate that risk.
A little bit more on
the threat assessment.
So I showed you the map.
I showed you the attacks
of what's going on.
And these are the
kinds of things
that we're paying attention to
is to put more into that risk
model.
Who are our attackers?
What kinds of things
are they looking for?
What are the high value things
that we want to protect?
And use that to
inform our decisions.
But the other thing
that we have is
because we do this on
a very large scale,
we capture a lot
of data and we use
that data to help us
make these decisions.
And I'm going to come
back to that in a minute
because that is an important
point here in a second.
Niels talked about the
eight layers of the stack
this morning.
And I thought that was
a fabulous presentation.
Let me talk to you a little
bit about some other kind
of intangible pieces of that.
One of the, I wouldn't say
necessarily intangible,
but one of the things that
we've done and we continue to do
is we foster a very
strong security culture.
And we make security
everybody's responsibility.
We train people in security.
We partner up with each other.
When we see common
problems, we'll
address those and
educate our employees
to be vigilant for these kinds
of things and avoid stuff.
And through doing all of
these kinds of activities,
it helps in simplifying
the problem because we
have many hands on the problem.
We've got people
thinking about it
and we've got people
collaborating with each other
to reduce these risks and
simplify the problems.
Part of that culture is also
giving back to the environment
that we live in.
And so what I'm showing
you here is just several
of the innovations that
we've come up with over time
that we've shared with
the broader community,
and we hope that you
take advantage of.
For example, two
factor authentication
is a big thing that is
really important to us.
We use that on all
of our employees.
And it's just the
way we do business.
And it becomes part
of that culture
and it becomes a regular thing.
And it doesn't become
difficult for your employees
to do to help
protect your assets.
Niels and Joe talked about
all the infrastructure
that we built and everything.
I won't spend a lot
of time on that.
And then the other piece
of it is that we're
very operationally vigilant.
And because we have this
global network, which
I can show you in my next slide,
we have this point of presence.
I showed you the
threat map and what's
happening in our environment.
And we have this global network.
And we're in over 33--
we're just basically
around the globe, which enables
us to deliver applications
with very high performance
to users all over the planet.
But also our customers
in Cloud Platform
get to take advantage
of this network.
But because there's
networks everywhere,
we gather a lot of data.
And the point that
I'm trying to make
is that we use that to make
data informed decisions.
And so what I'm about
to do is I'm going
to hand things over to Aaron.
And he's going to talk
to you about a tool
that his team has built
that uses a lot of data
to help wrangle the
security problem.
AARON PHILIPP: So thanks Matt.
Again, just by way of
introduction, my name's Aaron
Philipp, the head
architect on our solutions
that we're doing under
the banner of something
called Reinvent
Security together
in our Google alliance.
And just talk just
for two seconds about
really how this comes
together in practice.
If you look at PwC, we
have a massive amount
of business knowledge, how
organizations run globally,
how they manage risk,
how they address change.
You look at Google, what
they have from a technology
standpoint, being able
to take those two things,
put them together, is something
that as we've gone out
to our clients and as we've
gone out to the market,
both from where their
needs sit and then
also what we've been
able to do to help them
has been enormously impactful.
What I'm going to
talk about today,
and this is kind of a subset
of our security portfolio
that we're working on
together with Google,
is what we generally call PwC's
Security Analytics powered
by Google.
And there's two main
components to this.
One is the actual
security analytics itself.
And the other is something we
call the Threat Intelligence
Fusion Center, which
allows us to take threat
intelligence from points all
over the place worldwide,
fuse it together,
actually understand
what it means, what
the risks are, and then
map that into the organization.
We've actually-- and generally
when I talk about this,
people are surprised by this.
But we've actually been doing
this type of work for years,
for some very,
very large clients.
We built out really our first
cyber analytics platform
in 2012.
And I'll give you
a little background
on why we had to do this.
We were working a major
investigation at that point
where we had something on
the order of 500 servers
were compromised.
We had about 550
billion artifacts
that we had to get through,
many, many, many terabytes
of data, which at
that point in time
was a fairly large
scale set of data.
And we had about
three to four weeks
to complete the
entire investigation.
And I'm not sure
how many of you are
familiar with kind of
traditional forensic techniques
and those types of
things, but they simply
were not going to cut it.
And so we went and we looked and
we said, all right, how can we
actually accelerate all this?
And we built out our first
platform, figured out
how to pull in data
programmatically,
how to actually look at all
those images at once, how to
map that from a
normalization standpoint
into the 550 billion
artifacts we had on top of it,
and how to actually--
and this is really
what was most important
for our clients--
how to map what was happening
in the business on top
of that technical data.
And we did all of that in one of
our labs in DC with about a 30
to 40 node Hadoop cluster.
So being able to take data
that would have taken us days
to search using kind
of traditional methods,
cut that down to something that
we could run through Hadoop
in about four hours, we thought
we were all now data scientists
and it was going to
be amazing, right?
But let me tell you a
little bit about what
happened at that point.
We ran our first search.
And the first search ran on
about 250 terabytes of data.
And the result set
was five terabytes.
And we realized very quickly
we had to get much, much better
from an analytic standpoint.
Because how we
were doing-- and we
were state of the art at
that point in time as far
as Hadoop forensic analysis.
But what we were
doing simply did not
work, because the data that
was going in was too big,
and the data that we
still had to cull through
after the analytics
was way too big.
And so we had to really
redesign and look
at how do we layer in other
things that are nontraditional,
whether it be information
about the business,
unstructured data that's
very difficult to work with.
How do we start hooking
this stuff in, right?
And we really started
a four year journey
of a lot of lessons
around just that.
How do we take in a PDF
that comes from the US
government that has a series
of technical indicators
that we need to go look
for and immediately
operationalize that, right?
And how do you make sure that
somebody doesn't inadvertently
type in a keystroke wrong,
and then all of a sudden
you're firing up all
kinds of false positives
you didn't know about?
Being able to solve these
problems at small scale
is kind of an
interesting problem.
But being able to solve it at
the scale our clients demand
from us on a single engagement,
and then what we do globally
at that scale, is a whole
different ball game.
And so we built this
stuff out internally.
And when we started our
alliance with Google,
we first kind of approached
them and said hey,
we've got these kind of
interesting security tools
we're using internally.
This could be a really
interesting alliance
where we come together,
use your platform,
take what we know about
how to actually do
these types of analytics, how
to layer in the business risk,
and do it at a real scale.
And that's what we did.
And so I just gave
the example of being
able to take a query from
days to four hours in a Hadoop
infrastructure.
We now have that
running essentially
interactively in a
matter of seconds
using things like
Google's BigQuery, right?
And that's really
irregardless of scale.
I'll talk a little
bit more about this
when we start talking about
some of the real world stuff
we deal with.
But to just give you an idea
of what I consider scale
and what we consider
scale, we have a client
that's coming up that
has a requirement for 50
petabytes of data,
five-zero petabytes of data.
The proof of concept
we're doing with them
will encompass about 10 to
15 petabytes worth of data.
That's what we consider
to be-- I will call
that moderately large scale.
There's stuff above it.
But we have to be able
to address that need,
because that's what our
clients are asking from us.
So I have had the
good fortune of being
able to really kind of go around
the world over the past 12, 18
months and talk to really some
of the strongest companies
and strongest public sector
organizations worldwide.
And this is what has come
out of these conversations.
When we talk to these guys--
and it's really interesting,
because irregardless
of sector, irregardless
of where they're located,
these are the general themes
that come out.
Number one, data volume
massively increasing, right?
This is lead, because
of the problem
I was mentioning before about
imprecise analytics creating
a whole bunch of alerts, a
whole bunch of false positives,
this has led to a massive
backup in the people
monitoring these alerts, right?
If you look at any major
breach, the company
will actually get ripped apart
because someone will invariably
find an alert in
their security systems
that would have notified
them about that breach that
was unaddressed.
But let's be fair that
organization for half a second.
It is not uncommon for a
large scale organization today
to be taking in 10,000
to 15,000 alerts per day.
Being able to cull that down
from 10,000 to 15,000 alerts
down to the five
that really matter
is a massive, massive issue
for companies worldwide.
The other problem they're having
is because of the large data
scale and what they're having
to do on the infrastructure side
to build out
storage, maintain all
the regulatory
requirements, actually
be able to look
at the data, they
are having to make artificial
decisions about what they look
at and what they don't look at.
And they're making
these decisions
not on the value of
the data necessarily,
but they're making it based
on the size of the data.
And so what happens is-- and we
see this over and over and over
again in our incidence
response practice where
we go in what we call kind of
right of boom after something
terrible has happened
is, they don't
have the data necessary
to actually complete
the full picture.
And the reason they
don't have that data
is because they had to make
this kind of artificial choice
about what they wanted
to keep and what
they wanted to give away.
And that really goes
down to this concept
of limited budget,
insufficient processing power,
wealth of data not being used.
And then the last
thing I'll talk about
is the inability to extract
value out of the data.
And this is something we've
seen on the private sector side
and it's also something we've
seen in the public sector
side where being able to
tell good data from bad
and actually linking the data
together correctly and showing
how it joins-- so you may
have something that seems
worthless as this point
up here, but being
able to link it with
vulnerabilities,
be able to with
threat intelligence,
be able to link it with what's
happening in the business,
and actually do all of
that at scale and at pace
is a very, very hard problem.
So when we looked
at what we wanted
to address with
this solution, this
is really where
our heads were at.
And so we came up
with these four kind
of foundational requirements.
One we call
automation detection.
And I'll explain what
that means in a second.
Two, superior
intelligence, being
able to take in
threat intelligence
from all over the place,
and make best use of it
at scale-- absolutely critical.
Visibility of everything,
not just focusing
on the technical data,
but actually understanding
what it means to the
business and the organization
as those alerts come in,
as they are prioritized,
and as they're dealt with.
And then lastly,
real time analysis.
If you're not able to do
one, two, and three at scale,
in real time-- you
know, there's not
a whole lot of value in
one, two, and three, right?
You can do some of
this stuff in batch,
but being able to do this in
real time and catch this stuff,
especially as stuff moves
into kind of these newer
infrastructures where you can
actually automate responses
in the infrastructure, is
going to be absolutely vital.
So let's talk about one and
two just for half a second.
Automation detection, what do
we mean when we talk about this?
Historically security
analytics, writ large,
has been about pattern
matching, signature analysis,
kind of first level.
first order analysis.
Some of the more advanced
stuff that's coming out,
maybe certain
types of clustering
and those types of things
around basic counting, right?
It's really interesting
when you see kind of what,
in these really advanced
clients, what works
and what doesn't, I can kind
of break it into two buckets
from what we've seen.
Things like anomaly detection,
machine learning, those
are what I would call kind
of near time predictive.
So maybe they can
predict to an hour.
Maybe they can break to minutes.
They're not going to give you
a week warning or two weeks
warning or three weeks warning
that something's happening.
Generally they are there to
find the unknown unknowns that
are already occurring
in the network.
And there's a massive
amount of research going
into how to do that better.
And the great news for us is
having a partner like Google,
being able to take what they're
doing in the machine learning
side, leverage that into these
types of business problems
is actually really,
really interesting.
I'll talk about
that in a second.
But when you talk
about long term,
actually getting ahead of the
threat, threat intelligence,
by far, is where
that sits today.
And this is understanding when
a sophisticated threat group has
started up a new campaign
and understanding
they're hitting some
other region of the world.
And we know from past
experience that they start
there to test all their tools.
And once they're
comfortable with everything,
they will then move to
the US, or whatever region
you happen to be in.
Having that kind of visibility
and that kind of view,
and actually being
able to operationalize
that, is absolutely critical
for organizations going forward.
So we look at these
number one and number two
as kind of this near term
and longer term thing.
The other side of this is
going back to the machine
learning concepts, being able
to take in some of things
like the image recognition and
image classifier stuff actually
can marry into visibility
of everything, right?
So being able to take
unstructured data that
are screenshots or desktops,
those types of things,
and being able to pick up when
a terminal window has been
opened, just by using
kind of image recognition,
is something that's very, very
interesting, because there
may be some obfuscation,
antiforensics they're
doing on the back end to not
pick up when cmd.exe gets run.
But we can pick that up
actually on the front end
using image recognition.
And I've talked around
this, but I want
to just hit a couple points.
And this is, when we talk
about this with our clients,
being able to kind
of dip into this,
for lack of a better term,
massive pool of resources,
whether it be compute, whether
it be storage-- you know,
I remember when I made the
phone call about the 50 petabyte
thing, saying hey, is this going
to be a problem for you guys,
the answer was no.
And it was not just
no, it was like tell us
when you want to
start, because we
can go ahead and just ramp this
up tomorrow if you need to.
So being able to do
that kind of activity
and being able to
throw 30, 40 nodes
if you need to at
just a parsing engine
because you have some
really complicated ETL
you're trying to do, and have
that still be cost effective,
is an absolutely
massive differentiator
when you look at how
things are done today
in security versus how they
can be done in the future.
So having said that, I
want to dive a little bit
into what we're actually doing
on the threat intelligence
side.
We do a lot.
It's interesting,
people think of us
as kind of an accounting firm.
Some of us know that
we have consulting.
We're actually one
of the largest,
if not the largest,
information security
practice in the world and
the consulting [INAUDIBLE].
And we have offices in, I
think we have 157 countries,
give or take.
Don't quote me on
that exact number.
We have hooks cross region
and around the world.
And being able to take data
from all those different client
bases and understand
what that means and map
that into some of the
other collection activities
we do is very interesting.
So we're actually
tracking around 110
different distinct
threat actors.
This generates a ton of data.
So just to talk through
what this actually
means from a what do you do
with it once you collect it,
our Threat Intelligence
Fusion Center platform,
we talked about what
we use internally,
has something on the order
of, I think it's 200 million,
give or take, documents in
it, from all over the place.
We've mapped that into a
very, very large graph.
And being able to do threat
analytics on that in real time
as data comes in from all these
different parts of the world,
absolutely, absolutely critical.
And when we help our
clients out with how
they solve these problems, we're
finding more and more and more,
they start collecting
threat intelligence.
Maybe they have some
public-private partnership.
feed they're paying for.
And they realize very
quickly they have a problem,
because they have,
one, they have no way
to operationalize it to actually
get it into their environment
to check what's happening.
And then two, even if
they did have that way
to operationalize it, they'd
have no way to rank order it.
And so what will
invariably happen
is we'll find out from them that
somehow IP addresses of a CDN
or some other kind of
massive infrastructure piece
have ended up on a blacklist.
And it just knocked out kind of
30% of their business process
because they inadvertently
blocked something from a threat
intelligence standpoint without
actually properly vetting
it first.
So being able to do
that type of analytics
as that data comes
in, rank order it,
combine it together, understand
what a low quality feed is
telling you versus a
high quality feed, what
the confidence difference is,
how to make those decisions,
and how to automate all of that
is something else that's, one,
for sophisticated clients,
very important now.
But as the kind of next
year, year and a half,
two years goes by, as more
threat intelligence comes out,
especially in the US around
some of the laws that have just
been released, is going
to be absolutely vital.
The other side of that too
is information sharing.
So how does that get linked
with companies together?
So if you have a
set of indicators
that you have gotten off
your network because you're
seeing some campaign that
no one else is seeing,
how do you make sure
that efficiently
moves across the wire to all
of your partners, to folks
that you have information
sharing agreements with?
And how do you make sure
that that doesn't somehow
have a knock on effect to
where you adversely disrupt
the business of a partner?
When you start kind of unpeeling
what these threat intelligence
concepts actually
mean, you start
to see what the challenges
from an analytic standpoint
are really starting to present.
So it's not just
about having pictures
of the building
these guys work in,
which is kind of
academically interesting.
But it's really
about, all right,
how do I use this
information to best protect
my estate, my business
partner's estate, and kind
of the ecosystem writ large.
So I'll talk a little bit
about what we actually
do with our Threat
Intelligence Fusion Center.
This was born out of our
internal practitioners wanting
to share data more effectively.
And so we had to build a
platform that would allow them
to very easily, seamlessly, and
frictionlessly upload these PDF
reports, Word documents,
text files, emails,
whatever it may be, drag and
drop them in, extract out
all the indicators, and
then actually operationalize
that data.
So there was a
massive amount of work
that went into figuring out
how to, when you drag and drop
a PDF in, how to
rip out kind of all
the technical data
in that report,
and then create
a workflow around
that so you have second and
third level reviewers actually
saying yes, this is
what we think it is.
Yes, we're assigning
this confidence to it.
Yes, we think it's this
malicious, et cetera,
et cetera, et cetera.
Because when you start
getting at the scales
that we operate
at just internally
and also our clients
operate at, 95% accuracy
is not good enough
because that can
mean massive amounts of massive
amounts of false positives
and massive amounts of hits.
So there is still
very much still
a role for kind of this process
wrapped around the technology.
Being able to integrate with
third party solutions that
actually allow us to
go out and interrogate
the infrastructure-- so hooking
into a solution such as Tanium
or one of these
endpoint solutions
is absolutely
critical, because those
are the tools that
are going to have
the visibility at the endpoints
to be able to push and pull
this data and actually allow
us to pivot very, very quickly.
When we look at kind of
the life of a SOC analyst,
security operations
center analyst,
and kind of the SOC
1.0 architecture
which exists today, they spend
hours switching between tools,
switching between
technologies, switching
between online-offline
stuff, going out
and investigating things, trying
to pull all this data together.
Typically they jump into some
kind of Excel spreadsheet.
They create some
kind of timeline.
It's not uncommon for
these SOCs to have
one guy whose entire
job it is to maintain
some kind of
spreadsheet of metrics.
If you take that
and actually move
to kind of this integrated
architecture concept
where all the threat
intelligence is married
to all of the endpoint
technologies, which
has a massive analytics backbone
behind it that actually allows
you to overlay the business
risk on top of that
and see it all as kind
of one pane of glass
as part of the native
alert, what we're
seeing in terms of
operational efficiency
is just absolutely massive.
So they're going
from hours to days
to investigate an incident
down to half hour, 15 minutes,
eight minutes in some cases.
And so there's a lot to be said
for doing this work upfront
and actually setting
this single pane of glass
up and actually pulling all
the data into one place.
We went, just on the forensic
side and the IR side,
by doing that, our average
time to investigate a system
went from about
three to four days
down to an hour,
hour and a half.
And that's doing kind of
the full forensic analysis.
Because we automated
on the back end
and we parallelized on the
back end all the extraction
of that data out.
And we automated what we
could and we left the art
to the analysts to
be able to construct
what they need to construct.
It's my personal
opinion, we're going
to see these kind
of optimizations
all over the place.
And so when we talk
about machine learning
and those type of things, those
things are very interesting.
But just being able to
get the data in one place
and have all the data
present for analysis
is actually going to be huge in
getting efficiencies out of it.
So I want to talk a little bit
about what a proof of concept
looks like for us.
These data numbers
are a little small
compared to what we're actually
doing now on proof of concepts.
If you look at what
we're doing currently,
we actually have
a proof of concept
where we're taking about
six terabytes of data a day.
We're maintaining that 30
millisecond processing time.
So that's everything
from ETL all
the way through to analytics,
threat intelligence look up,
et cetera.
Instead of 2 million queries--
which is still a great number.
I'll talk about
that in a second--
we're actually seeing about
45, 50 million queries
being run against that data.
So the more you get the data,
the more you make it accessible
and the easier you
make it to query,
ironically we're finding
people query it more.
Which is great.
So let's talk a little bit
about this proof of concept.
So we started out with I think
there were 32 use cases that
were going to be completely
custom built for the client.
We started taking in data.
We took data from about
400 different log types.
We took it in as just
kind of a massive stream.
We had them mirror off their
existing log infrastructure.
Within about 36, 48
hours, most of that
ended up having to be
a bit custom parsing.
36, 48 hours, we had 96%
of the data parsed out.
I think in the next
week we had something
in the area of 99.5% parsed out.
And then we got the last
0.5% when we needed it.
So being able to have
that kind of agility
and being able to scale up,
just transparently what you're
doing just on the
parsing side and actually
make that data usable
that quickly, was massive.
Because we started receiving
data on a Thursday.
And then the
following Friday, we
were down there with
15 custom use cases
fully executed through,
and showing them
stuff that none of
their other security
tools or other
security platforms
had been able to show them.
And a lot of that goes
back to how quickly
we were able to spin up the
Google infrastructure, how
we were able to use
those tools, how
we are able to not have to focus
so much on absolute efficiency
of the code, but actually
just getting it to work,
and then able to cut to make it
more efficient on the back end
as we could scale it down.
Really interesting story kind
of about the 2 million queries
run-- 1 million of those were
run within a 24 hour period.
That kind of a spike, on a
lot of on-prem platforms where
they just have a couple servers
running and they're running it,
would have absolutely
tipped the platform over,
would have just crashed it.
The only notice we had that
something was a little bit
up was we got an email
saying hey, can you
check connectivity.
It looks like the platform may
be running a little bit slow.
And actually what
happened is we kind of hit
the limits on the scaling.
We upped the limits
within, I think, two hours.
No downtime, no anything else.
The entire platform
was back up to normal.
Another really interesting thing
that we found out about this,
and we actually found about it
after the fact-- I didn't even
know this until the CSO
told somebody else about it.
They decided to do a stress
test on the infrastructure
and find out if they could
crash our infrastructure,
because they wanted to
see what our limits were.
And so they went ahead and
they just, without telling us,
they tripled the amount
of data coming in.
And we didn't even notice.
All of the speeds, everything
else kind of scaled up.
It all kept running,
no problems.
Being able to do that because
of what Google's put together
and their infrastructure
and what we're
doing in these kind of
cloud native technologies,
you try that with an
on-prem-- and they did try it
with an on-prem technology,
and it crashed and fell over
and took the other group a
couple days to actually get
back to operational form.
And this story occurs
not just at small scale,
but large scale, which is great.
So when we actually look
at what we're doing here,
every piece of
threat intelligence
that sits in our threat
intelligence portal, the Threat
Intelligence Fusion Center,
is looked up in real time
as that data comes through.
So for our internal
instance, that's
about 22 million indicators,
massive number of indicators.
For clients it's generally
a bit smaller number.
But it gives you an idea
of what you're able to do
and actually able to rank order.
And this all results
in being able to take
in multiple
dimensions so you can
look at threat intelligence.
If you have a hit,
you can marry it
to what's actually
on the system.
So what the business
risk of it is?
Does it contain
third party data?
Are there certain
vulnerabilities
that we know about
that are on the system?
Does it play a
very important role
in certain types of
business processes?
And how does all of
that link together?
And being able to use
that to rank order
the criticality of the alert so
that you can start pushing down
some of the noise alerts
and actually using
some kind of interesting stuff
to fully marry those out,
and then really
raising to the top
the ones that are going to
impact the business in very,
very critical ways.
And so just the punchline
on this proof of concept
is we were side by side with
another company at the time.
In the time it took
them to, I think,
execute five or six
custom use cases,
we were actually able
to execute on 38.
And it was so much so that
they actually asked us--
and this is something really,
really interesting as well when
you use these types
of cloud technologies
where you have this
open data architecture.
The fraud team found out
about this and said hey,
we know you're doing a bunch
of stuff on the security side.
But you have that
data sitting there.
Can you do that data for fraud?
And within I think
a day or two, we
had a couple
dashboards put together
showing how we could use
all the same sets of data,
with a little bit of additional
stuff from a transaction
standpoint, financial
transaction standpoint,
to show how we can now
take that same data
and have a fraud
alerting system.
And they're looking at this
now saying wait a minute,
we have all these
different infrastructures
in our environment that are
collecting this type of data.
And we have many different
copies of this data.
Why don't we just have
it all in one place,
and then all these
different groups can use it.
So we're now seeing
the applications group,
the infrastructure group,
the security group, the fraud
group, some of the customer
satisfaction groups,
are all looking at
how they can use
the same data with different
cuts in different ways.
And that's when you
really, really start
to get to very
interesting things,
because then you're
able to, if you
see something on the customer
satisfaction side-- somebody
calls into a call center.
They're trying to
social engineer.
And you want to marry that
up to what's happening
on a database at the same time.
That becomes very easy
because all the data is just
sitting there.
And you can start to do these
really, really interesting kind
of data driven analytics.
And I'll go ahead, and I just
have a couple screenshots here
just to talk through.
This one's what I would
call fairly basic,
but just to show how we're
able to put a lot of this
on one pane of glass where you
have stuff coming in from all
over the place, all these
different devices, and then
also actually showing the
type of data that resides
on these different systems.
And being able to
link all this up just
is part of the native platform
and something our clients have
found to be enormously useful.
Anomaly detection-- we
have anomaly detection.
Just to walk through, this
is a very basic example
of how we would do this
with firewall data.
We're actually able
to use with user data,
we have a portfolio of
five different algorithms
that we use for
different things,
depending on what
the situation is.
And we can run anomaly detection
kind of on your basic stuff.
But then actually when you start
to get to user activity, data
activity, all those
types of things
where you start to get some
really, really interesting
use cases on the
anomaly detection.
And this is really all about
driving to the unknown unknowns
that you may not know about.
And I don't know how
many of you have worked
with anomaly detection
before, but it
can be very messy to deal with
because when an anomaly fires,
there's generally very
little context of why
that anomaly fired
other than to say,
this is what we're looking
at, and we found an anomaly.
So being able to have all
this data in one pane of glass
to where you can drill
in very quickly to all
the data around the anomaly and
understand what was happening,
both with the event
itself but also
at the baseline understanding
how it typically looks
is something really,
really critical.
And I have talked about
this already a bit,
but full threat
intel integration.
This was something
very important to us.
So it's not about having two
separate systems, one that
manages threat intelligence
and then one that manages
the lookups against the
threat intelligence,
but actually having all
of that connected together
and being able to
act on that data
in some kind of algorithmic
way, really, really critical.
Because we see time
and time and time again
from a process standpoint,
when an organization
has those two
systems disconnected,
threat intelligence get
missed, because they
invariably for some reason
will not move that over.
It moves over in batches.
The other side of that too is
when you introduce new threat
intelligence into
the ecosystem--
so you have some new report
that just came out from ICS-CERT
or whatever it may be-- being
able to do that retrospectively
and say automatically
every 24 hours,
go back and search my logs
for all of these indicators
and tell me if I have
an issue, and then
have a report sent out
nightly on that is something
really critical as well.
In the second screen shot
you'll see down here,
you see kind of the
beginnings of what
looks like a network graph.
The other thing that we see as
being really, really important
is being able to
actually keep all of this
in one related structure.
Because you will start to
see kind of these emergent
patterns pop out when
you do it that way.
And if you're using some of
these smaller scale graph
tools, which are phenomenal
tools in their own right,
and you kind of have
these different versions
of each threat group or
different versions of what's
happening, you are going
to miss connections
between threat groups,
between tools usage,
between infrastructure.
So to make this concrete,
we see time and time again
where an individual has
defected from one threat group
to another, especially in some
of the cyber crime groups.
And also the cyber
crime group picks up
a whole new range of tactics
that they never used before.
Being able to pick
that up and to actually
understand what's happening
underneath the hood there,
and the fact that somebody
may have moved over,
and also now whenever you
go up against group X,
you need to start looking
for all the attacks
that group Y uses as
well is enormously
beneficial to our clients and
protecting kind of society writ
large.
Being able to do that
without all that data sitting
in one place is a very,
very difficult exercise.
So it's absolutely critical
to keep very, very noisy data
at scale and then understand
how to kind of rank
order that data up and down.
So endpoint
monitoring-- and there's
a kind of massive conversation
going on the industry
now about agent versus no agent,
when do you deploy an agent,
when do you not need an agent.
And it's really fascinating.
So this entire dashboard was
created with no endpoint,
with actually no
agent on the servers.
We were actually just
using the native logs that
came off the server to do this.
Typically it's
actually very hard
to do these types of things
because a lot of this
came out of a certain type
of event log type that's
very, very unstructured, very
difficult to deal with, very
hard to parse.
Being able to use
Google's platform
and actually scale it to where
we can really just hammer
away and parse
that stuff at scale
and not to worry about
throwing 20 nodes
at it allows us to create
this type of visibility
into the environment where
we can say, explicitly,
on any system that contains
third party data, whether it be
regulated or otherwise,
these are the programs that
were added and removed.
These are the users that did it.
This is the time frame.
These are the security tools
that may have been turned off.
And to do all that
without agents,
especially on some of the older
systems, is absolutely vital.
Now having said that, if they
do have agents out there,
we want to be able to take full
advantage of those as well.
And we do have-- we've
spent a lot of time
because we think
it's really, really
valuable to be able to push
and pull from those agents.
So if we want to take all
the data they're seeing,
pull it into dashboard and do
the analytics, but then also
we want our analysts to be
able to pivot on that data
and interrogate the
endpoints themselves.
So if they see
something in this where
they may want to
do a second level
and actually pull a hash
value that gives them
a fingerprint of one
of these programs,
we want them to
be able to do that
without having to
leave the ecosystem
and pull up yet
another pane of glass.
And this is really all about
joining this stuff together.
Lastly, we've got to have
eye candy at some level.
And this is that eye candy.
But it does actually demonstrate
a really interesting point,
which is we're able to,
as the data comes in,
fully geolocate it, do
all the anomaly detection,
do all of that kind of stuff,
map it onto this visual,
create this really kind
of interesting soft visual
that while it looks pretty
and all those types of things,
can actually convey
information as well.
Because all of a
sudden if you see this
and then you see a massive
connection going to a country
you know you don't
do business with,
that should fire up an alert.
Somebody should
go run that down.
And so it's really
all about creating
these kind of novel
and interesting ways
to look at the data.
That may have been possible with
certain types of infrastructure
before, but we really
want to be able to do that
across the board, and do that
in a cost effective manner,
and do it in a manner that
helps organizations best
protect themselves.
And that's really
what we're focused
on when we talk about our
security analytic solutions
and how we're helping
our clients kind of move
through some of
these problem sets.
So with that, I believe
we have finished with kind
of two minutes to spare.
So I want to say thank
you, everyone for listening
to the presentation today.
If you have any questions,
we'll be around up here
after the talk.
Otherwise, thank you for
hanging out for the last slot.
And have a great one.
[APPLAUSE]